well thank you for the leading clap I
was next
especially in the post lunch slump which
I'm sure everybody's in so if you just
want a sort of nap or fall asleep I'm
gonna be offended so I'll put ours a
disclaimer so we're talking about the
evaluation fairness of machine learning
I just want to start by saying that
we're going to talk about an extremely
limited definition of fairness you know
I'm not an expert in ethics or in social
sciences that my backgrounds engineering
a machine learning so people have been
thinking about biases and data and the
fairness of decision-making for a far
longer time than I have and it's a very
mature field but Fennessy machine
learning is a very interdisciplinary
field and a lot of the papers have
really only been arising in the last
couple of years and so I'm going to talk
about it specifically in the machine
learning context and in that context
it's where we have what we call
protected attributes so these are things
that we know about people which
describes a group that they belong to so
people are in different subpopulations
and this sub population is described by
some attribute and the idea is is that
people within each of those groups
should be treated fairly because we know
a priori that it doesn't affect the
output of the system there's also in
this case no consideration of any
historical biases towards members of
each group or societal structures that
already discriminate against them
because in if before you build your
decision learning system or your
decision-making system
people are already discriminated against
in some other way then there are often
some policy levers we might want to pull
in order to negate historical biases so
I'm not going to talk about that it's
going about a very limited context where
we know which groups people belong to
and we want to know how do we make a
decision in a fair way ok there's a
broad spectrum of course of decision
making and the unfairness can arise at
both ends of the spectrum so even for a
human decision making can of course be
bias and so you can automate the
decision making and I suppose one
benefit of doing it in an automated way
is that perhaps we can at least probe a
little more than we can probe somebody's
brain into how the decisions been
so maybe it could be more fair maybe not
I think we'll find out but there's a lot
of issues and one of the outcomes will
be that the most important thing is that
we're at least evaluating how fair would
be when we can automate the decision and
we could also lie anywhere in the
spectrum here so we can use perhaps
producing a score which enables people
to make decisions or we at least put in
some prior distributions based on expert
knowledge and those could be biased as
well so there's biases from the human
side advices on the machine learning
size and the biases can come in anywhere
in the machine learning pipeline okay I
mean there's a very coarse step but in
general we start with data collection
which we're not going to talk about
really today and this is actually really
interesting collection of essays I'll
put that far too small but it's called
raw data is an oxymoron and it's a bunch
of historical studies showing that
really data is never neutral data is a
sort of a cultural concept and something
that we all share and the idea is that
it's really impossible to collect that
in a way that's purely raw so purely
unbiased and so we should really start
considering at the very beginning are we
collecting data in an unbiased way and
perhaps dropping data there's going to
skew our decision making or account for
things or biases that we know are in the
data if they can't be helped and then a
very cool area and I find really
interesting is the area of algorithm
design it is extremely cool but I'm
going to talk about it today and this is
how can we train our models on the data
in order to minimize fairness so how can
we structure the models and how can we
design them from the ground up so they
have fairness baked into them whatever
definition of fairness is and we'll come
on to that and there's another really
interesting paper which is on archive
which is called avoiding discrimination
through causal reasoning and this is a
really interesting paper where they use
Bayes Bayesian models to introduce
causal relationships so we can
explicitly say this protected that
should be does not affect the output and
these ones do and by having that as a
hard constraint in the system then we
can essentially train the model to learn
that this this group membership does not
affect the output and again that's album
design and we're going to talk about
that too much but today we're going to
focus more on decision making so the
context is is we have a train machine
learning algorithm it's maybe a black
box and it just gives us ones or zeros
or it gives us a score or equivalently
we have a human-rights the same thing
they sit there we can't probe their
brain but they just deliver some sort of
decision to us when we ask for it so for
example a judge and we want to
understand how can we analyze the
fairness of that decision-making process
or in the constants of machine learning
how can we use the outputs of the learn
system in order to make fair decisions
okay so we'll start with evaluating
fairness because we haven't really
defined what fairness is so a common
example is a police stop and search so
here we have chief Wiggum and Homer and
they're driving around and they're going
to stop people who they believe to be
unlawful so they're going to go and do a
search and then if they have some
contraband on them then they get
arrested and they want to minimize of
course stopping people who don't have
anything on them because that can be a
traumatic experience for somebody but
they also don't want to miss people with
contraband that are out in Springfield
because then that's also a negative
thing for the public to have unlawful
citizens around and they've taken two
different approaches so chief Wiggum has
some reason extremely suspicious eyes
and maybe we expect that and he's
looking around and he's trying to
determine I'm just using his natural
functions
he has cognitive faculties who he thinks
is unlawful and therefore who he should
stop Homer on the other hand I have no
idea if this was actually what was
happening in this scene in the Simpsons
I haven't seen this episode Homer is on
a laptop and maybe he's actually
inputting features that they see into a
deterministic machine learning system so
it's pre-trained and he just gets back
for example like a probability so based
on things I typed in there's a 70%
chance that this person is unlawful
now it is of course and everyone's
interests that as they drive around
Springfield and Shelbyville I think is
at the other town in Shelbyville in the
Simpsons they weren't a tree people from
those two towns equally because they
have no reason to believe that just
because you identify as being from
Shelbyville that you're more likely to
commit to Khmer crime so I'm going to
try some audience participation but as I
said it is post-lunch so I understand
this could this could fail horribly so
maybe I'll just ask people upfront how
would you go about insuring how would
you go about stopping people to ensure
that you don't bias against people from
Shelbyville and Springfield ignoring the
fact that in the Simpsons they probably
would definitely be vast force people
from Shelbyville okay no I don't have an
idea yeah yeah so just like completely
randomized search maybe like stop every
tenth person yeah that's a good it's a
good one I don't have any more or maybe
that's the first one that comes to mind
yeah
yes that's another very good one and so
one problem with the randomized search
is that if you're trying to do that in
sort of blind to the protected
attributes we say oh we don't we think
he'll we're doing just going to stop
every tenth person there maybe they end
up driving round you're right like
Springfield more than Shelbyville so
they happen to be stopping people in
Springfield way more often and so the
approach certainly seems bias and
actually will be biased and unfair
towards people from both because they'll
miss criminals or unlawful people here
in Shelbyville and there may be stopping
people more often than they should in
Springfield so yet you could control for
that I don't have anything yet
yeah okay yeah so you stop something
from Springfield then if you stop next
person then they said I'm from
Springfield as they are don't worry and
then we go to the next one right yeah
the proportions are right yeah yeah yeah
so maybe they were like I heart
Springfield hat yeah it's a really good
idea and and so in these kind of
scenarios I'm more going in a minute to
evaluate these and all of these
different options will come up there are
lots of different ways where we get some
black box scores and we have to make a
decision that affects people's lives so
for example loan approval insurance
premiums so this is particularly
relevant to my day to day work at slice
hora I'll come as i briefed at the end
of course there's going to be a hiring
slide and for example detention rates so
who knew how do you decide who to arrest
or there are scores assist judges that
actually exists and also the reoffending
rate has been unheard of a compass
school this was very newsworthy yeah a
few people and so this is a score and
that was developed in America which is a
black box score which helps judges to
evaluate whether a criminal is likely to
Rhea fend for whether they should
release them early or whether they
should stay in so these are really black
box models that are affecting people's
lives and in any case when there's any
risk or probability and we have to make
a decision we need to be quite careful
about how we're applying it okay so the
first idea which may be the randomized
stopping would involve is the idea of
fairness through unawareness and
actually I think like a huge proportion
of machine learning actually just comes
under this this banner so this is we
don't use any protected attributes and
as long as we don't put them into the
system then we're not really being
inherently unfair and we do accept that
maybe there'll be some correlating
variables where we say oh you know but
you know that's just how the data is and
and we'll build it but of course that
doesn't really work because you end up
learning proxies for the protected
variable which means you're still being
unfair so this is the wrong example I
came up with it was intuitive to me but
I don't if it is to other others and
I've got the idea from this paper on
counterfactual fairness which
you should definitely read it's really
interesting so the idea is is that we
believe there's some latent variable so
we don't we can't observe this which is
the criminality of a person and that
criminality of course directly affects
whether they're being unlawful so in a
stop and search we believe that some
people that we're driving past in
Springfield are really have some level
of criminality to them which correlates
with whether or not they're going to be
carrying some contraband and it also so
happens for some reason that they prefer
McDonald's quarter pounders with cheese
over crusty burgers with cheese and
that's okay criminals can do that if
they like but it also so happens that
people from Shelbyville prefer
McDonald's over crusty burgers and so
you can see in this case we don't use
this feature this is the protective
feature whether people are from
Shelbyville Springfield so we decided to
ignore it but we do observe because
we're trying to ingest like as much data
as we can people's preference over for
crusty burgers over McDonald's and you
can see from here that if we regress or
we learn try to learn unlawfulness
through this latent variable through
whether people prefer crusty burgers on
McDonald's then you're going to
inherently be learning this highly
correlated variable as well so we're
gonna end up discriminating for people
against Shelbyville I think it is
actually proved in this paper that if
this is a linear regression then this
actually ends up being a fair way to do
things but in any nonlinear setting then
you're going to learn you're essentially
going to learn to be biased and in this
case this is quite a positive link so
the idea that people prefer crusty
burgers is kind of seems quite innocuous
but there are of course other more baked
in things in society for perhaps if
you're born into a certain area and
there's less opportunity for you then
perhaps that means you have attributes
about you when you're older that aren't
related to these protected attributes
but that we think are kind of safe to
correlate on so for example in in credit
risk of course income will directly
relate to whether or not you can pay
back your loan
but of course we accept that some people
born into a situation where their income
will be inherently lower and so that's a
very very similar set up to what we have
here but it's a course a quite quite a
negative situation
okay so we'll come with some definitions
of fairness I think this is one that
cropped up the most between people and
this is what's called demographic parity
so here we have two populations one is
orange and one is blue this is a
minority population in the majority it
doesn't really matter the important
thing is is that the distribution of
people the predictive distribution is
the same for both classes for both
groups so for example in the police stop
and search this is the people that we
stopped ie we predicted that they would
be unlawful and whether or not they
actually turn out to be or not the idea
is that we stop the same number of
people and that seems quite fair I think
that's what came from over here so stop
people representative Lee or similar to
driving around Springfield and
Shelbyville it's the same idea we're
trying to get equal proportion in both
and actually this has been used in
police stop and search and it's called
benchmark tests so they're just making
sure that you're not stopping
proportionally more from one group
members of one group the members of
another group but it has problems of
course the fundamental problem is if the
underlying base rates in each of the
groups really are different so in this
case in the orange class so c1 is like a
true positive and oh sorry whether the
the true label is one and the true label
is zero and things to the right of this
line we predicted as one and predicted
as zero so again if we think about the
stop and search case these are people
who really had contraband on them people
that really didn't have contraband on
them so more often people are being
unlawful in this first group then in the
second group
so there are I think we can see here
that it might not be fair for example
for this group because half of the
people that are stopped and not
criminals
so for them their utility is very low
like this is a very unpleasant
experience for them potentially and
likewise if you look on this side
out of the people that were missed half
of them were criminals so criminals seem
to be getting away with it more often
and so if we think about this in stannum
notation that you could apply to any
machine learning algorithm it's the idea
that the probability of being in class 1
is essentially the same no matter which
group group you are and this is a binary
classification problem which take the
discussion to that so that's the idea of
a benchmark test that you're equally as
likely for example to give a loan to
every person in each group or you're
equally likely to detain somebody in
each group but if the underlying base
rates are different then it doesn't
really work out so the next thing we can
try
is we can condition on the true outcome
so this is essentially that false
positive and false negative rates so in
this case if you look at the total
number in both groups if you look at the
total number of people that are being
unlawful in both cases we've managed to
catch half of their criminals so that
wasn't true in the last case where we
were catching a larger proportion of the
blue criminals than the orange criminals
so can you see how that might be unfair
and you can see how this joins with
people's experience that they say oh
well you know more criminals proportion
they're getting away with it in the
other group and if we can also have that
our false positive rate you can also
make sure that that's the same which
actually isn't in this case so this is
of all of the negatives what proportion
are we predicting they're they're
positive so in this case how many people
are we stopping that really aren't being
unlawful and in this case you can see
that know that nobody unlawful in this
group was being stopped which is good
but here 1/3 of unlawful people were
being stopped but if you balance both of
those then I can work quite across quite
nicely so this is conditioning on the
true outcome so are the error rates the
same for people who really are criminals
and are error rates the same for people
who really aren't criminals in both
groups does that make sense
I still get confused all the time now
with even after many years with true
positive false positive
- negative Fox negative so if I ever get
a mix-up or anything just shoots up a
hand or abuse me or shout okay the other
thing we can do is conditioned on the
predicted outcome so this is the idea
that of the people that we predicted to
be criminals
was the proportion the same over each
group so for example what have I done
here oh so here you can see that of
people we predicted so let's just look
on the right hand side that two-thirds
of the time we were correct and that's
the same for both groups so you realize
that's different to beforehand where
we're saying the proportion of true
criminals being stopped in each group is
the same and here is the proportion of
predicted criminals in each group of the
same and both of these could be seen as
unfair but sorry both these offenders
criteria if you don't match either of
them then you can be unfair in different
ways
so here the criticism would be well more
criminals are getting away with it in
group a than in Group B and here the
criticism is that you're stopping people
more often in Group A than in Group B
who who really are criminals and these
and how all of these criteria in these
fairness criteria can be entirely
written in terms of the false positives
true positives false negatives and true
negatives and if you go to this paper I
which came up fairly recently you get a
whole list of all of these fairness
criteria in a coherent notation which I
find really useful because these these
different metrics for fairness often
have very different names or conflicting
names or they use completely different
notation in the literature so this is a
very good way I found - I could get
everything down get the notation set and
so I recommend taking a look at this can
everyone read that it says fairness in
criminal justice risk assessments the
state of the art but unfortunately there
is inherently and impossibility
condition so this is what we're going to
talk about so imagine here this is the
the outputs for a lot of people in the
population and I've colored the two
groups again orange and blue and they're
ranked from the machine learning or the
human decision-makers probability of
being an
of course so in this case the
probability that they're carrying
contraband so on this side we're pretty
sure that they're not going to be
carrying anything whereas over here
we're 100 cent sure that they've got
something and so you can see that the
distribution is pretty messy but there's
definitely more true criminals to
remember the the black means that
they're really carrying contraband and
the hollow circle means they're really
not carrying contraband
so people so it does seem that we're
doing kind of well on both groups so
let's think about firstly the benchmark
test so oh no this isn't a benchmark
test see I'm already getting confused
this is just equal to rash holding so
fairness through unawareness and we just
say okay well we don't care what group
people are in but as long as we predict
that there's like over a 70% chance that
they're carrying something then we'll
stop them I probably that would actually
be quite high maybe it's more like if
it's over tempers then you want to stop
them I'm not sure but you can see that
this is unfair by a number of metrics
many more are getting stops
proportionally or maybe the proportions
are quite good but you can see here that
half of the people stopped here weren't
criminals and here everybody was you can
also see that more criminals are getting
away with it in this group so it doesn't
work but we've already covered that and
you could put that slider anywhere and
you're going to have this problem so
this is the threshold in so again maybe
these are all the people we stopped and
those on and we again have these kind of
different distributions of false
positive rates and false negative rates
so one thing we can do is we could
actually apply different thresholds to
each group now if you realize a
fundamental difference is that we now
have to know the membership of each
person within the group so now we've
moved away from fairness through an
awareness and we have to actually
account for this protected variable
which goes against a lot of what the
intuition is which is like if we don't
want to be biased we just shouldn't
include those things in the model but
here we need to know the groups and
again they don't actually have to be
inputs to the model but we need to at
least know when we do the evaluation of
the decision-making we need to know
which group people are in
and here we've got the case that half of
the people being stopped no that looks
like proportion of criminals being
stopped the size of this this is their
benchmark test so we've had the same
proportion of people on the right as you
do on the left
so we're stopping people proportionately
fairly which is again what came from
over here we should just walk around and
we should make sure that people have
stops at the same rate in each of them
but the problem is is that here we only
got half that half the people we
predicted are having a quite horrible
time because they weren't really
criminals whereas here many people were
stopped so we could adjust the sliders
again and you can you can see I mean I
won't go through every example but you
can see that we can move these
thresholds and you can change the false
positive and false negative rate well
much like when you have your ROC curve
for example and you're changing the
threshold but in this case it's kind of
like you have two ROC curves one for
each population and you can move those
thresholds and you're adjusting the
rates for both and you either want to
get the false positive rates to match or
the false negative rates to match or
ideally everything and so it's perfectly
fair if all of those fairness criteria
we spoken about a true but the
impossibility condition
unfortunately says that if the data is
not separable which we had here so we
can't draw one line that clearly
separates true criminals from truly not
criminals
if the data is not separable and the
base rates within each group are
difference with a true number of
criminals in each room for different
then we cannot have fair we cannot be
fair on errors condition on true
outcomes and errors condition on
predicted outcomes so in other words we
can't be fair both in the proportion of
criminals in each group that are stopped
and the proportion of people that we
stop that end up being criminals and if
you if you think about it one of those
is more to do with the individual who's
being stopped and one is more to do with
society and this is in this paper and
it's mathematically proven inherent
trade-offs in a fair determination of
risk scores so if you take a look at
that and you can basically see that even
if we know the probability if we
calibrated our classifier so it always
got the probability correct for each
group so if we say Oh
persons 50% likely to be a criminal and
they really are 50 10 likely to be a
criminal will actually end up stopping
people at the wrong rates in in each
group this is a difficult pill to
swallow there's how they phrase it in
the paper and I think that's true
so in summary how can we achieve
fairness well we cannot achieve fairness
in both the predictions and the outcomes
it's rarely fair to use the same
threshold for everybody but in a way
that's also a policy in a debate point
we need to choose one metric and that
metric depends a lot on the domain
knowledge so you really need to know for
a given example whether or not it's
worse for people to be stopped when
they're not really criminals or whether
the proportion of criminals being
stopped is the biggest problem and this
is again this is a very limited national
fitness fairness and it's only one
example but in the case of for example
loan applications maybe one outcome is
not as bad as another so commonly with
loan applications people would say it's
more important that those who need a
loan able to get it than those who then
just make sure that the right portion
people in each group are getting a again
in line so it depends on the utility of
the individuals and so you really have
some domain knowledge
so in summary measure all the metrics
which is easy and machine learning but
not so easy for humans so I'm just
really going to quickly talk about a
very interesting paper which was to do
with police stopping procedures in North
Carolina and I took the stop and search
data for the UK and I try to apply the
same model I did apply the same model to
get an idea of whether there's bias ease
in the way that people are stopped and
searched in the UK and so the procedures
this a policeman is driving along in the
car and they observe the probability of
somebody being unlawful now if you think
about the data we have we only know the
proportion of people stopped because the
police write down we stop someone and we
can normalize that by the demographic in
a given area so if we know those far
more people have Group A and Group B
then we can make
there that that benchmark test is
correct that the right proportion of
people are being stopped and we can also
observe the results of the search
because they note down if nothing was
found and if something was found so we
can make sure if we can check that that
outcome distribution is also the same so
the procedure in the model is this and
there's a lot of assumptions baked into
it but the that people walking on the
street have a probability of being
unlawful and police officers have a
threshold which can vary for different
groups so for example it could be
ethnicity or gender but we allow that
threshold to vary for each group but
it's constant throughout that group so
perhaps they've stopped males and a
different threshold so that they stopped
females so they observe the probability
and if the probability of that person
being unlawful is below the threshold
then they're not stopped and if it's
observed to be above the threshold then
it is stopped now notice here that these
are all latent variables so we don't
actually know the probability that
people are unlawful and we also don't
know the threshold but we're going to
try and infer those okay so just quickly
on the data that I collected and just I
just want to really show that this is
extremely limited and I don't think we
should really draw any strong
conclusions from the outcome it's more
exploratory and the reminder that we
need to just try and measure these
things as much as possible whether it's
human decision-making or machine
learning decision-making so stop and
search data exists for the UK anybody
can download that and they record they
write record every time they've stopped
somebody and the officer defines the
ethnicity and they also ask the person
to define their ethnicity that
correlation can be very interesting and
and there was a detail like what they
were looking for like why there was
thought and if they really found
something but we don't have a stop right
so that you have to go to the UK census
data to get the demographics for each
police area so to figure out whether you
know in some there's a higher number of
one ethnicity living there then perhaps
in another area of the UK and so you
need to adjust for that to make sure the
stop rates affair because you can't get
that from this alone because you only
have the positive examples
so I use the arrest rates data which
already maps the census data to the
police areas so it's very limited
firstly the stop rates we have aren't
real numbers because they're relative to
the population in the area and of course
the way police and do the search is to
like meet every person in the population
and check but the proportion of the
demographics is correct so it's like an
unauthorized variable so when we when we
see stop right in a minute
the number itself does not have meaning
but it's the ratio between numbers it's
important
okay so I'll skip over this quite
briefly but this is what the model looks
like we have the search rate and this
will depend on this probability that we
model that's basically the this is
essentially a coin flip problem so you
you look at someone and R is the
ethnicity or the race so we we let that
vary between each and we're saying so
there's a probability that a person that
we stopped is unlawful and then we check
whether or not it's above the threshold
for that ethnicity from the police
officer and then if it is we flip a coin
and we stop them with the probability P
and then when we search them they also
turn up something with a probability P
and we place priors on these I'm going
to go into it in too much detail because
they're running out of time
this is a simplified model I coded up in
PI Z 3 and the reason it's simplified is
when I was putting this together a
couple of days ago I ran into a
limitation and I thought I would still
share the limitation with you and the
problem is is that when you do a Thresh
holding problem it's kind of like a
survival analysis you know you want to
you you you know the probability that
the person carries contraband has a
certain value and we have a threshold
but you want to essentially do like
greater down so this random variable
greater than this random variable and
that gives you kind new distribution and
then if you know this kind of concept
from survival analysis and there's not a
baked in waste through that in pi mc3 so
I ran into I think I described this as a
human limitation which is that oh maybe
I didn't put it there
oh yeah I couldn't get the I couldn't
code it in Fiona who basically which is
the
against behind c3o give them more time I
think you could so I don't want to
berate the developers but I ended up
using Python for the full model in the
end because that already has that
supportin so shout out to the developers
of both of these projects because
they're both incredible for
probabilistic programming but this in
this particular case was a limitation so
here's a really simplified model of that
which is essentially we have a
probability that people will be stopped
and an if they're stopped there's also a
separate probability they're carrying
contraband so in this case we're
modeling the probability that someone's
carry contraband given that they're
stopped
there's no relationship between the two
and so this one looks like in aggregate
all of the UK
I also hope you've got a hierarchical
model which is training right now so
while check a bit finish but I think
it's probably not wise to show the
results if they haven't been checked but
so this is the stop rate at the top and
again remember the numbers themselves
are not like interpret of all but the
difference between them is and so you
can see here that there's a huge Delta
between the stop rate for for blacks
being stopped versus white emit I should
also say mix is a huge outlier because
very few police counties allow the
officer to use a definition mixed so
most of the counties the the options for
a police officer are asian black other
and white and mixed isn't an option so
that's why i'm here you have a huge can
you even see that and i it's a very flat
distribution so for mixed so that was
less reliable but you can see the stock
rates are really different and so now
we're starting to understand why the the
stop and search in the UK was of course
again very newsworthy and people have
had very negative experiences and now we
can start to interpret maybe why that is
and again i don't talk about fairness
too much but certainly it makes sense
that people from some populations can
clearly feel that they're being treated
substantially more unfairly than others
especially given that we don't actually
know the proportion through the base
rates the the real proportion of
criminals in subpopulations so that's
that and then you have the hit rate here
so this is that given someone was
stopped
did they have contraband so this is like
given and we assigned a pause
of label was it really a positive class
so this is what we looked at earlier
which is conditioning on predicted value
and you can see here I think very
interesting so the agent population is
much lower and so this suggests that
they're probably being stopped they're
those from that group of being stopped
too often because when they're stopped
they're less likely to actually have
something on them so this does start
suggesting a bias and again the mix is
like a huge huge outlier on here okay
but in this case we didn't measure the
latent variables this is already in the
data and building the probabilistic
model just allowed us to fit not only
the expected values but also get an idea
of the robustness of the estimates so
then I moved to PI Stan and so these are
the results so on the left you have the
search rate and hit rate again but now
we have these latent variables that
we've learned so up here is the
threshold that we predicted for the
police countrywide to to stop people and
here the the inferred probability that
people really have contraband but but
this is the interesting one and first of
all I think it's very important to note
that these distributions are extremely
built broad and overlap a lot and
they're very Wiggly so really I think we
need more data to make any conclusions
but we do start to see that there could
be some disparity between the
subpopulations and a threshold or the
standard that police have in order to
stop people in each of those groups and
then we're just do min on the the bottom
on a bit oh I didn't include that but
this is very squished up on there but
you can actually see that all in all the
chance of someone being a criminal in
each group is extremely similar
especially up here in the tail perhaps
there's a little more weight so you can
see it drops down here then than others
and so this is the exact underlying
problem we saw I left for the
impossibility condition that if the
underlying base rates and again we can't
observe them perfectly in this scenario
but these are inferred based rates if
these base rates are really different
for each sub population then it's very
possible it is impossible to be
completely fair by every definition but
I think what's important is that we
measure all the different definitions
that we started to understand whether
within a given context living this
helpful police stop and search if they
could have been more fair and I think
here we're starting to see that both the
search rate the hit rate and the
thresholds vary by group and not in a
systematic way so I think there's
definitely a lot of investigation to be
had here into whether police are being
unfair towards certain ethnicities no
there are no hierarchical model results
or everyone for that okay so in
conclusion there are inherent trade-offs
if we want to maximize fairness firstly
through the different metrics of there
are for fairness but also something we
didn't touch on is that there is an
intrinsic tension between classifier
accuracy and classifier fairness we have
conflicting definitions and then in
general we should apply our domain
knowledge in order to determine whether
something is truly fair and I know they
said the definition of fairness goes way
beyond all we spoke about today finally
I think the one thing that I drew from
doing this investigation myself was that
you should measure everything measure it
or measure the false positive rates
measure the proportion of which you're
predicting one class or denying people
loan applications in any of these
contexts or in the contest in assurance
whether we give someone an insurance
policy or not we should be measuring all
of those rates to try to determine that
you're given the main whether or not the
decision being made is fair
so yeah I'll take okay I'll do questions
after the hiring we're hiring at site
Ora
so that's ice hora we're developing risk
models for the insurance industry and
then helping them to differentiate more
between potential insurers so if you're
interested in machine learning you're
interested in any of these roles these
are senior or junior where we're
recruiting for all so can i speak to me
if you're interested in risk modeling
and now i'll take any questions we have
time for a couple questions
[Applause]
yeah first of the back I think Oh gone
yeah I think Sam you mentioned it
at one point early on about learning
from a proxy variable is he isn't the
problem in a linear model yeah yeah
actually I wish I wish I could really
elaborate on it I haven't gone through
the paper much depth but did you get the
reference that I put did you notice it
down yeah can't special fenders so this
is like a specific definition of
fairness that says within a
probabilistic model if you hold all
variables the same and flip the
protected variable then the output
should definitely not change and this is
the kind of simplest example of that so
it's like if you hold you know if you
hold all of these and you flip
shelbyville then that's going to also
flip your observe variable so that by
the definition of counterfactual
fairness I think isn't fair but I think
that authors are probably gonna call me
off this and say I'm like completely
destroying their work but the idea is
that actually in this very simple
example a linear model happens to
satisfy this very specific technical
definition of fairness yeah I would
definitely read it out because it's
interesting my question is this is your
work related to social choice theory in
economics and I'm thinking in particular
of arrows impossibility theorem so I'm
not completely familiar with the second
theorem by can maybe comment on the
first part and if you told me a
definition now I'm sure I'd probably
just stall on a spot and try and come up
with an answer our arrows theorem said
to me you're gonna do here are three
characteristics for a voting system you
can't have them all oh I see I mean it
sounds like it would be similar but
certainly in economics and social
sciences that's been force about a lot
more and when I mentioned that there's a
trade-off between accuracy and fairness
then if you ascribe some utility
perhaps do false positives or false
negatives you know they're usually not
the same in terms of utility and also
the utility for society if the accuracy
of the classifier is wrong then there is
some social utility theory in choosing
the level of fairness that optimizes
utility for everybody in society I'm not
sure about that Aras impossibility
theorem I'm sorry
gralton okay thanks everyone thanks very
much
[Applause]